what's your style
my style
[Music]
the expression jack of all trades master
of none is often used in a derogatory
manner but there are other expressions
that can describe a jack-of-all-trades
all-rounder polymath multi-potentialite
and they're awesome here's why it's
better to be skilled in multiple
different aspects of fitness
you can do you
one of the best things about training
different modalities is that it means
you're free to pick and choose what
works for you sometimes an exercise or
move just doesn't click with us we find
them uncomfortable or boring or even
painful or maybe they just don't feel
like they're doing anything conversely
there are those moves that just work i
now have a catalogue of 20 or so
exercises that i pick from whenever i
want a good workout fast i feel these
working i like how they feel and they
agree with my physiology and i found
them from a wide variety of different
training modalities from strength
training to calisthenics to gymnastics
to yoga to dance
it's more fun for me training across
disciplines is simply more fun and
exciting there's always something new to
explore training never gets dull or
repetitive and whenever you hit the
plateau you can simply find a new avenue
of performance to explore
it leads to breakthroughs
true breakthroughs happen when you
combine ideas from multiple different
sources i recently watched an inspiring
video from jimmy the giant about a guy
called william spencer william made his
name by posting skateboarding videos
unlike anything the community had ever
seen before skateboarding videos
combined with parkour-like movements and
flips what was the response from the
community initially well not entirely
positive while there were no doubt fans
there were also a lot of haters
commenting that spencer wasn't a real
skateboarder but he was just an
attention seeker but these were just
circus tricks
in what world is this not cool though
how can people be so blind to something
awesome just because it isn't exactly
what they've been doing all this time
of course william went on to become
extremely successful and even worked as
andrew garfield's stunt double on the
amazing spider-man you know who else
took from multiple disciplines to create
something entirely new bruce lee and
without him we arguably wouldn't have
mma today
you never lose
i know for a fact that i'll never be the
strongest guy in the world or even the
gym
by lifting weights just a little bit
though you're automatically stronger
than 90 of the population seeing as most
people don't lift weights
but if you meet someone who's stronger
than you you still have that knowledge
that you might be able to outrun them or
perform a handstand push-up which they
might not be able to do they might be
strong but you're now adept in all
aspects of your physicality
this also has practical benefits if
you're ever in an altercation you have
multiple skills to fall back on first
try and talk your way out of that
situation or outsmart the aggressor
failing that try to outrun them if you
practice sprinting and endurance there's
a good chance you'll get away
if that didn't work you could try
climbing over a fence or onto a bus
shelter to get away and if you still
haven't lost them then there's a chance
you might be able to overpower them you
remain adaptable with multiple types of
fitness you're ready for anything
someone extremely strong will be helpful
anytime they need to lift something
extremely heavy but if that same person
finds themselves being chased they might
quickly run out of breath likewise
someone who has a ton of endurance could
come unstuck when they need to help
carry a friend who's passed out but if
you're above average in all these areas
you'll be ready for a much wider variety
of potential scenarios
better yet many scenarios will actually
require a combination of these kinds of
abilities watch any action scene and the
hero will likely exhibit strength speed
stamina reflexes quick thinking and
agility all at once or in rapid
succession and many skills actually
support one another more mobility can
mean a deeper squat and more strength
more strength can help a runner travel
further with the same effort
you avoid imbalances
training in a single modality can often
lead to imbalances and overuse injuries
we see this commonly in sports in fact
many of the most common injuries are
named after the sports that caused them
that includes runner's knee jumper's
knee tennis elbow aka climber's elbow
golfer's elbow aka lifter's elbow the
list just goes on many runners struggle
with tight id bands many bodybuilders
and powerlifters find they get out of
breath easily even if you don't get
injured focusing on only certain types
of movement will result in areas of
weakness the body is built for variety
all these activities are good for us but
just as too much of one healthy food can
actually cause health problems so too
can stick into a single repetitive
movement pattern or just a few
everything in moderation which is to say
everything relative to everything else
you make more progress when you focus on
just one skill or trait you'll
experience diminishing returns at first
you'll enjoy noob gains and get much
stronger or faster very quickly but once
you're established you'll find yourself
adding just a few pounds onto your lifts
or shaving just a few seconds off your
run times
conversely if you're free to explore
different avenues of fitness and
performance you'll be able to become
highly skilled in one area and then
learn something entirely new once again
seeing a huge step change in terms of
your overall performance you explore
your fullest potential i liken the
approach of specialization to fixing
just one part of a car if someone
promised to revamp your car entirely and
all they did was change the tyres you
might feel let down similarly an mot
shouldn't just focus on one aspect and
ignore the rest to make your car the
best it can be you should focus on
everything from the wheels to the engine
to the ignition to the windows
can you tell i don't know much about
cars you can also look at this as min
maxing but the point is if you only ever
focus on stamina you'll never know how
strong you could have been how mobile
how fast how powerful
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did please
leave a like and share around that helps
me out immensely and comment down below
let me know what other reasons there are
to practice multiple different
disciplines which modalities do you
incorporate if you like the idea of an
approach that combines lots of different
methods into a single program you'll
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training that combines
strength training with mobility
endurance brain training agility and
more there's a link in the description
and it's currently on discount
either way thank you so much for
watching this one subscribe if you want
more like this and hit the bell button
to get notified each time we upload
thanks so much guys
and bye for now